This right here is a
picture of Fibonacci,
one of the most famous
mathematicians of all time,
and he was a mathematician
in medieval Italy.
And he's most famous for
the Fibonacci numbers.
And he didn't discover them.
They were actually discovered
several centuries before him
in India, but he popularized
them, especially in the West.
And the Fibonacci
numbers are super simple.
The first two are
defined as 0 and 1.
And every number after that is
the sum of the previous two.
So what I'm
constructing right here
is really a Fibonacci
sequence of numbers.
So the next number
in the sequence
is going to be 0 plus
1, which is 1, Then
the next number after that
is going to be 1 plus 1,
which is 2.
Then the next number
after that 1 plus 2 is 3.
2 plus 3 is 5.
3 plus 5 is 8.
5 plus 8 is 13.
8 plus 13 is 21.
13 plus 21 is 34.
And the Fibonacci
numbers, especially once
you start getting into
number theories, tons
of fascinating
things about them.
But probably the
coolest thing about them
is as you add more and
more terms to the Fibonacci
sequence, and you take
the last two terms
that you've generated, obviously
there is no really last two
terms.
You could keep going on
forever, get arbitrarily
large Fibonacci numbers.
But say we take these last two
terms over here, 21 and 34.
If we take the ratio of
these two, 21 over 34,
this is going to be pretty
close to the golden ratio.
And I encourage you to look up
the golden ratio on Wikipedia
and the internet.
You'll find all sorts of
fascinating and mystical things
about the golden ratio.
What's cool about the Fibonacci
numbers, or the Fibonacci
sequence, this gives
you an approximation
of the golden ratio.
You'll get even a
better approximation
if you add another
term to our sequence.
So the next term over
here, 21 plus 34 is 55.
So the ratio of 34 to 55 is
even closer to the golden ratio.
So one way, if you
wanted to compute
a really good approximation
for the golden ratio,
you could really just get
super high Fibonacci numbers
just adding the previous two
terms to get the next one.
And you will get a pretty
good approximation,
when you take the ratio
of the last two terms.
Now that's what the
Fibonacci numbers are about,
and now I want to pose
a challenge to you.
I want you to write,
since we've already
done some examples
using factorial,
I want you to write
an implementation
of a function that generates
the n-th term in the Fibonacci
sequence.
So the function
will be like this.
So if I call your function--
Let me make it a lowercase.
Let me just give
you some examples.
So if I take your function,
and I call Fibonacci--
and you could really implement
this in any language you want,
although we've been
dealing in Python,
it might be simplest
to do it in Python--
if I call fibonacci of
1, what I want this to be
is the first term.
And just to make things
clear, and you should always
clarify this, especially
in computer science,
because it's not always
clear what the first term is.
And I'm going to make
it clear right now.
The first term is not going
to be this one over here.
I'm going to make it
this one over here.
I'm going to call
this the 0-th term.
That's the 0-th
term, and then that
is going to be the first term.
This is going to be the second
term, third term, fourth term,
so on and so forth.
And so Fibonacci of
1, the first term
will be this right over here.
It should return 1.
So Fibonacci of 0
should return 0.
Fibonacci of 3 should
return 0, 1, 2, 3.
It should return 2.
Fibonacci of 5 should
return 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
It should actually return 5.
And what I want you to
do is write a function
so we could put in
any argument over here
and it will return that third
term of the Fibonacci sequence.